c'est l'histoire d'une image d'une
petite fille devenue l'icône d'une
politique
une jeune hondurienne de deux ans en
pleurs elle illustrait à merveille la
séparation des enfants immigrants à la
frontière américaine
il y a bien eu plusieurs milliers
d'enfants emmenés loin de leurs parents
le problème avec la petite fille est née
la marelle là c'est que elle elle n'a
jamais été séparée de sa mère il y a des
traits communs entre ce manifestant
palestinien et la liberté guidant le
peuple
le tableau d'eugène delacroix l'un des
pins une révolte 1830 l'autre une
contestation très actuel le blocus de
gaza imposé par israël sur la petite
bande de terroristes autres
contestations coloré celle des gilet
jaune en france on est étouffée par le
gouvernement on est tous faits par les
taxes par la tva par les pouvoir d'achat
on est tous et à tous les niveaux
il ya là bas
une contestation qui a dérapé à
plusieurs reprises à paris et puis il y
a le donald trump isolé au g7 dans
charlevoix
il quittera le manoir richelieu avant la
fin du sommet ou encore le donald trump
précurseur premier dirigeant occidental
à s'afficher avec le dictateur kim
jung-un les états unis n'ont pas été
épargnés par les désastres naturels
comme l' incendie qui a ravagé paradise
où l'ouragan michael en caroline du nord
et des désastres humains la tuerie de
parkland qui a fait 17 morts dans une
école secondaire de floride
space x malgré les déboires de son
capitaine elon musk a poussé d'un cran
la conquête spatiale
la prouesse ce n'est pas tant stars
mènent dans sa tesla roadster mais la
fusée qui langue la plus puissante sur
le marché et dont les lanceurs peuvent
être recyclés ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal
[Musique]